Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Those Nights at Rachel's 2. Now if you remember the Joy of Creation, this was made
by the same person that made that delightful game.
And is the official sequel to Those Nights at Rachel's - which if you remember
I don't think I actually ever finished, but this one should prove to be
beyond scary, beyond anything you've ever seen before, and
totally serious a hundred percent of the time. Hello, ah
Faz, my favourite drink. Oh Fizz? Hey, that's not what you said!
Oh!
"My day at the new Doug and Rachel's, my day at the new Doug and Rachel's"
Why'd he - why are you shooting an animatronic at Doug and Rachel's? My new day at Doug and Rachel's with a gun and grenade!
"My new day at Doug and Rachel's, my new-"
Huhuh, huh, hm
I don't think I'm gonna enjoy my time at Doug and Rachel's. I just have a funny feeling about that super void. "My new day..."
Well, Fredbear and Bonnie are dead,  all right... Oh, glowy!  *alarm goes off*
Well that's a problem, hello?
Ooh, okay...
Uh-huh
All right, well that's new, well...
Oh?
*Dog barking*
Did I hear a borfie worfie? Oh!
Whaa - what the hell?
That's moderately creepy! Oh...
Oh, bang, bang! *laughs*
Ah, I feel like I should mention now that this game was, this game's from April Fool's so
Huhuh, uh this is, um...
I mean, what am I talking about, this is
Totally serious, absolutely serious 100%, totally canonical game about
(unintelligible laughing)
What am I gonna get the grenades you promised me that he would give me grenades
OH! Oh shit
Gaa get out of here puppos
no no no (laughing)
It's so well made for a shit posty game is actually pretty good
I like it
Now if there's an upgrade system, I'm gonna be very impressed
Oooo what's with this oh
WHAAA OH What the ffu- (Explosion)
Okay all right I gotta choose what to do with my 256 gigabyte card
I'm gonna choose to unplug you.  Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay?
well, I didn't get to the end of the story, so you know I really got to retry that one I
Gotta try it again. Give me my gun give me my deagle
Oh good I can snipe now
(Laughing) It's just the way
That's really creepy that's not okay don't like that well
Haha sorry
Sorry Old Yeller I had to put you down
Oh boy, I love it so much
All right come get some
Huh?
See in the darkness Oh i don't like that
It's not good sign when citing down
Doesn't help my aim at all and my aim is already the stuff of legends I know
oh yeah, oh yeah I got you I got you I got you Sorry
Is there anything... Oh I can't actually go down that way
Okay Come on!
Come along then
Puppos
Something doesn't feel right about this
And also when I died last time did that dog get in my face and then blow-up
Because boy that's
That's
That's interesting (laughing)
huh oh
Alright where are they coming from?
aha there you are coming from
Not today not today not today
aha Not today
ohh this is actually
woo huh oh huh oh huh oh
I didn't  knowww hooo
woo HEY woo where? Where? Where?
oh oh
Oh okay that's good
Got quiet. I'm running low on bullets
(Strange growling) uh uh uh uh ah ah AH No NO
Well I don't like that at all
Okay, well that's scary. Why would you do that to me?
Ha oh oh oh hey oh hi
Oh you got a tiny okay then. (Giggling)
Okay.
Uh 7?! 7 am? This is bullshit!
What kinda bullshit are you talking about here?!
oh uh oh oh uh oh
You.
Uh uh oh Oh OH Oh oh oh no oh no oh no
Oh you (Explosion) AAAAAAAAAHHHH
Ah...
(Laughing)
It's so well made
I gotta keep going for it. I gotta get the high score.
Alright I gotta also conserved my ammo.
I can't miss or else I'll die
Okay, all right well
Hello (Laughing) Hello (Still Laughing) It's just everything
That's not okay. That's not okay, oh, that's not okay
Alright here we go all right all aboard the crazy train one more ti-
I mean the happy trade (Goofy Clownesque Laughter)
I am having good time here. Oh, you puppos shouldn't have to come to this neighborhood (More Goofy Laughter)
Boink. What happens if I get a ah
Body shots aren't worth as much. I've just screwed my high score
No. No. No. Bad dog. (Laughing)
Bad bad dog. That's a bad dog
Dooop oops
No, I wasted a bullet, I'm doomed
Still bark when they're on the ground well, that's not good you nah do now dude you bastard
No you're coming down that way oh
The bun okay all right in the bud over here all right, man. He's stressful. Okay?
I should reload make sure I have bullets in my gun
Okay which way are they coming from
Ha! HA! NOOOOO! C'mon
Gotta get I gotta get I gotta get I gotta get our. I'm gonna get it oh
You're gonna get it. Oh oh
I'm gonna get to get it. Oh, man
You know these games from Nixon have more polish than some triple-a team
No, it's just a tipos mission coming down the hallway, but even so it's so good
Is that a barking out here? Whoa better put you down?
Wha shit a mist well, that's probably gonna come back and bite me in the face
Oh
Refill I can refill
That's wonderful. I didn't know that I could refill
Over there
Boy okay, I'm just gonna stay here
Okay
Go home
I'm really trying guys. I don't know
There's an end of
Troy okay, all right, I'm all loaded up, and I'm ready to cock
I retract that statement
Ready to cock as much as I thought I was paid
And there's some deviancy on your shots when you go will you wish you watching
Skill we put skill we definitely don't let him get back close
You got this I got this we got this all right. I'm ready to clock. I'm so ready to cock oh
Whoa no
Okay, okay, okay
No, I know I don't need to refill 10 a.m.. There's a new record. It's a new county record oh
Oh
Oh oh, no, oh that's bad
It's a quiet ride our it's quiet our study time
Okay bye good bye good. Bye
Okay, oh boy, that's not good. Okay, all right, okay?
I hear bar where it is barking coming from there you are
Okay, all right pretty good. Good pretty. Good pretty. Good pretty. Good pretty good
No get you okay?
Waffle
Do-do-do-do-do it's a barky bark over 400 foot in your face. You are shot roof equal 400 foot
I don't like saying these things well. I'm singing a song
I
Appreciate the
Good
Okay all right
Is there an end I don't know if there's an end it doesn't seem like there would be an end I think it seems like
It's just endless but uh
What's that puppet bastard
But let me go to endless I haven't unlocked endless mode cuz I haven't beaten story murder fuck alright, I was close I
Must have been close
Let's do it again, let's go again, and let's go around the band again. Let's go again
Huh, ah
That's not a set number of bullets man thing. That's a set number of times. I can refill I think ah
So I should really
Understand I get it you can stop yelling at me now. I know okay. Oh, that's not good
Oh boy oh boy, oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy?
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy.
Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on.
Oooo. BAAAAAAAAA... BABY
Oh shit... eugh... eugh...
Well, come onnnn.
Euhhh
Son of a tit. What are you doing to me? What are you doing? What are you doing? I'm gonna reload now anyway, I think
Oh shit. Shouldn't have been there.
Okay.
Uh oh.
Oh boy
Okay!
Eeeeh dee du dee duh dee. Oh 20 AM. 20 AM! Oh Boy! I..
Eawaugh... oh shit..
Okay
Well that's.. eugh, that's a lot
Oh boy.. OH boy... oh.. ohh boy
Okay, all right well bonus jog down the hallways with the raccoons oh
Wahh, Oh shit that was dangerous I almost flubber knocked it all! Right at the end. I don't want to do it oh
Uh oh. Oh. Oh. Uh uh uh uh uh uh uh
Just in case... you know
What??
That's not good
For Iowa this is a problem, oh shit got it I didn't expect that to work oh
That's another one
It's a puppet copter um right okay?
Right
oh
Okay
I guess
I don't have a time limit or anything - I just keep shooting and is it is it a
Quantity of bullet thing or is it just a quality of shot things
Okay, all right, this is ridiculous
Quit being pathetic
Way to do it, but I
All right anyway, so that was those nights of Rachel's - apparently there's an endless mode
But I have a funny feeling it's just the same as the other ones so
Give it a try
Yeah, and also if you want me to go back and finish those nights at Rachel's one
I think I only did one episode of the first night, and I don't even know if I beat it but uh
There that is there there that is that is that that is that thing that that is
Just you know, just it just to give it a taste of endless motivations. It's probably exactly what I think it's
Daily, oh, I'm just willing to bet that it don't end you know what I'll just let them yeah
Yeah, I don't feel like going through all this again
Well there you go if you want to try for bragging rights you can play this game through the link in the description below and
Yeah, let me know how high you score and also if you want me to see the end of those nights at Rachel's one let
Me know about that, but also
So thank you everybody so much for watching as always I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye